The Dark Army approaches, my lord.
But there is still time for us to escape.
Why do you think he did it?
I offered him land
to last his families a lifetime over.
How could one be so stupid?
Mitsuhide's prejudice grew beyond repair.
Hojo Daimyo warped his mind
and fed his anger
with power and corruption.
[lord] I was referring to me.
[grunts] And look at you, Yasuke.
From servant to samurai.
The only one who didn't betray me.
-[metallic clink]
-We should drink to that.
We do not have time for this.
The Daimyo is going
to bring hell through those doors.
Let them come.
They are the guest of honor
to our little party.
I--
[Nobunaga] Yasuke, take it.
Drink with me. Celebrate this moment.
[raising voice]
What is there to celebrate, my lord?
Your forces are scattered.
Your dream of a unified Japan is gone.
-The temple walls burn as we speak--
-I am still your lord.
If I die here,
perhaps Mitsuhide will letRanmaru live.
Are you sure he made it out in time?
He was smuggled out
on the last ship, just as you requested.
-Was he afraid?
-No, he was strong.
Good.
Now, all that is left for me
is an honorable death.
My lord, if we barricade the side entrance
and force them to enter through the halls,
we can bottleneck their forces
and then cut them down in waves.
-[grunts]
-[kettle clatters]
I appoint you, Yasuke, as kaishakunin.
This is my final command of you,
my friend.
What? I don't understand.
We could still fight back.
[lord] This is the only way
to save Ranmaru.
No, there is no honor in this.
-[wood cracks]
-[gasps]
[flames crackling]
[battle clamor outside]
[Nobunaga] Thank you, Yasuke.
[sword plunges]
-[gasps]
-[grunting]
[trembling breaths, grunting]
[gasping] What are you waiting for?
[groaning]
[yells in Japanese] Do it! Do it!
[yells]
[gasps, panting]